hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
hier heute meine liebe zuschauer endlich
mal wieder zu einer neuen episode von
luca reagiert auf die eu die besten und
ich habe jetzt schon kein bock mehr am
letzten worte eines sportlehrers alle
spiele zu mir
den hat er nicht gebracht jedoch sehe
ich gerade dass das video noch ein
bisschen weiter geht den nächsten clip
zeigt eine zuschauerin von mir wie sie
eine wasserflasche mit ins kino
schmuggels nicht nur gewaschen richtige
eine community besteht nur aus
vollidioten in der tat shama ich hab
jetzt bloß keine wirklich für die
information dass ich keine chips gerade
ich hätte gerade gern chips das kann ich
auch allerdings haben auch wieder ganz
ganz ganz ganz viele leute von euch
videos gepostet wie sie meinen job
promotet haben - danke für deinen
support du monster der sie bei ihrem
video anscheinend ein snapshot filter
genutzt hat er möchte ich euch an der
stelle ein video zeigen bei dem ich
diesen step chat filter genutzt habe wo
man als frau dargestellt wird also
genießt einfach die nächsten sekunden an
als er möchte allerdings auch noch kurz
erwähnen dass am ersten sechs neue
klamotten in meinem shop launischen
werden und zwar habe ich euch von den
fünf neuen produkten bereits vier
produkte gezeigt also ein popsong zwei t
shirts und ein rudi und nun zeige ich
euch den anderen oder launischen wird im
können
das ist ein schwarzer rudi mit einer
grauen kapuzen geblendet haben wir ihnen
dadurch dass wir hier unten ein
kunstleder patch angebracht haben das
besondere an diesem hobby ist und das
kann man leider über video glaube ich
nicht so richtig erkennen
das material ist neopren ja das ist neo
premier beim luca shop mal wieder keine
kosten und mühen gescheut und haben
etwas neues ausprobiert und dieser rudi
ist riesige felder schon am ersten sechs
und 15
wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten video
luca hast du jemals gesehen so was ist
man direkt an der autobahn grund denn
flächen wie wir es über winter laut ich
will jetzt überhaupt nicht respektlos
sein aber warum jetzt eigentlich das
video geht aber auch noch ein bisschen
weiter flur ist wichtig dass du das noch
mal erwähnt hast dass charlie von mir
hält manchmal höre ich mich selbst an
dem vogel das von war ein
videoausschnitt aus dem lied this is
america allerdings mit dem gesicht von
axel voss der youtube mit einer knarre
erschießt an der stelle möchte ich
wieder mal ganz unparteiisch daran
erinnern dass ihr bitte wenn ihr über 18
seid wählen geht zu den europawahlen die
jetzt in einigen tagen stattfinden
werden das ist wichtig denn über unsere
zukunft finde ich sollte nicht
hauptsächlich rentner bestimmen also
geht wählen
im moment mache ich nicht politisch
stark dafür dass leute wählen gehen und
dann ist das nächste video ein video in
dem jemand eine flasche durch sein
zimmer schießt wolle die content ich
kann auch klavier spielen
seine musik aber kein wasser wer nämlich
gott wieder so ein scheiß wird aber auch
für dich er dass die tür
[Musik]
ich habe mich ganz tief papa hat gesagt
ich sollte schwimmen hat eine kartoffel
um eine badehose tun dass wir viele
mädchen gefallen du hast leider
vergessen zu werden das ist die hälfte
zu hereinkommen sollen
koschitz gehirnzellen stehen oben schon
wieder schlange würde er ist luca auch
bekannt als cohen kraft beweisen
chris ist es ein sehr schlag über ein
komplettes spaß zählen begabter pianist
oder dem ein gummibär ein begabter
pianist es war ein komplettes post es
ist sonntag apropos sonntag ich habe
heute auch ein neues bild auf instagram
hochgeladen mit diesem neuen rudi hier
sogar der am ersten sechs in meinen job
lounge
das bild habe ich heute auf instagram
hochgeladen
da müsst ihr wohl vorbei und auch
instagram da kommste luca schlecht das
ist marketing aller zeiten
[Musik]
das heute wieder sagen ich habe ende
einer liebe freunde wir durch meine
reaktion auf diese instagram ii das mit
dem hashtag luca reagiert gefallen hat
dann schreibt sie und in die kommentare
und jetzt würde ich auch einfach nur
noch sagen lasst nicht nennen